what about writing prompts what if
you're kind of stuck with something what
do you use as a prompt I know you had
talked about going to a cafe only to
eavesdrop and get ideas which sounds
great but I know there's other other
things that can jog someone's creativity
and you know how do you have those in
all these writing classes you'll the
teacher okay take out a piece of paper
okay I want you to look at you know what
you had for breakfast this morning
something very simple like that but
there's other more sort of obscure sure
yeah I mean I think for just getting
something started like I I can't write
at all is almost oh it's almost a dream
to me now I think because you what
happens is you get in a place where
projects are lengthy and you're in the
middle of projects and so usually you're
you're fixing things or reinter you know
kind of reinterpreting things like so
you kind of already know where you're
going to go but just in terms of like if
I have a blank slate and this fictional
life where like all my projects were
finished I'm like what am I going to do
next I do love i love proms be early
early in my writing career I had kind of
one of those books that was the writers
book of days and and it just has you
know what is the coldest day that you've
ever experienced and then you can do
fiction you can do non non fiction the
coldest day just takes those words like
little you know there's the the one
where you open a book and pick a
sentence and then you right from that I
saw one the other day as I was flipping
through the short film book i'm going to
be using and it can't remember but it
was like they had something kind of
setup and the person has to make a
decision and so and i thought that was
really nice because it implies character
and action and motivation all in that
same thing whereas you know the coldest
day could end up just being kind of like
an elegy for snow on trees like this if
once you know there's a decision you
know a lot of things
so those kinds of things I don't know if
you've ever um you know I think when I
was working on my thesis I did prompts a
lot because i was on a deadline i felt
like it had to be perfect and one of my
girlfriend's bought me that writer's
block book that's like a block of
prompts and it has pictures and words
and things like that so i would start
off with that but sometimes even putting
myself on a timer and just going right
something you know just just the active
and finding you know like i'd end up
writing about dancing or music or you
know anything that that sound the sound
was often very because i had like a
little egg timer and just the ticking of
it i think i do think that I that I
connect rhythmically two things and so
like water like you know sometimes
showers are just a great problems you
know to get myself outside of myself so
there isn't I don't tend to use prompts
a lot but I do you know use music as a
way to get out of myself and into
something else you know but nothing that
sounds grand or fantastic it's it's it's
whatever gets me outside of myself is
what usually is a great prompt for me
you